mark's with us in seattle hey mark how
are you
hey good gentlemen how are you guys
doing great man what's up
uh first off just wanted to give you
guys thanks for uh you know everything
that you guys do
uh my parents are big rambears they went
through your class through church and
all that
uh they just kind of taught me
everything and i pass along my
brother-in-law's who are
big listeners and i'm sure they're even
listening now just had a
quick question for you i'm getting out
of the military here soon within the
next year
i want baby steps four and five right
now i have two kids and all that
i got about 15k in the savings uh and
when i get out we're looking at moving
back home
to florida or home for us uh
back to florida the question with that
is
my wife is able to transfer she's a
government contractor she makes
between 20 and 25 000 a year
but i don't know what i'm going to do
yet and so we're trying to figure out
when we go back to florida
if it would be smart for us to
you know finally get the house that
we've wanted we've been nothing but
renters
our entire life finally get uh get the
house we want
or should we continue renting until
i can find a nice steady job um
and basically go from there
you're not gonna get the house you want
with twenty five thousand dollar your
income yeah did you say she makes 25
grand a year
or 125 yeah uh 25 25 grand a year we got
about fifteen thousand in savings this
is
a little bitty house my man yeah i
wouldn't even transfer just go get a job
at
starbucks make 25 grand
okay yeah so no no you don't you don't
have enough income to buy a house that
you're going to be pleased with
okay and so i have the gi bill that uh
doesn't matter they don't they don't
give you houses they don't qualify you
for houses under the va
for that you can't afford okay
we'll if i went that route we'd still be
getting uh
i'd be getting about 1600 a month for
the housing allowance
uh as well as me working either
part-time if we go that route oh wait a
minute wait a minute
you're talking about the gi you're not
talking about the gi bill to buy a house
you're talking about you're going back
to school
yeah oh and you're one you want to take
the stipend and do that on top of hers
no you need to you need to rent until
you're out of school yeah
runs until i'm out of school yeah what
are you going to study
uh right now i'm just working on my uh
just general associates and then from
there i got a couple of different things
i'm looking at
uh possible uh looking at nursing degree
um and my eyes are kind of open right
now uh
i'm kind of getting out of the military
earlier than i expected
okay uh so we're just kind of open
anything right now
thank you for your service and you have
this wonderful benefit to have education
at your fingertips
education with no game plan as to where
it's going to take you
is known as a waste of time
so you need to spend the next few months
dialing in
a detailed career path and game plan
that then will tell you what kind of
education you need to get you may not
need a four-year degree you may want to
go into technology and get some
microsoft certs
i don't know i don't know what you're
going to do you may want to go in the
real estate business in which case you
don't need a four-year degree you need a
real estate license i don't know what
you're going to do with your life
but you need to dial that in and don't
just go to school because it's there
that's going to take you nowhere john's
got a phd
in higher education am i wrong no i do
and i've worked with veterans for years
who
they get out and then they come and they
just start going to school and think
they're going to figure it out on the
way
and then you you know those that are
dialed in and there is man there are a
few students
as as that you want in your class more
than a dialed in veteran who knows what
they're going after
he's got a game plan thank goodness for
this benefit that i think they
they fully deserve but yeah i'd rather
see you go work for a year
go be a nurse's aide go work in a
hospital go do something and see is this
what i want to do
don't want to dedicate the next four to
six years of my life doing this you do
not have to go straight into school out
of the military
okay in order to you know it does it
does not invalidate your gi bill
right and yeah the only the only thing
is uh trying to
set up something uh like i said i had
the two kids and all that so we're gonna
need that
some type of income uh coming in and her
uh
her salary isn't gonna really cut it
that's right that's exactly that's what
my point is and so buying a house is
down the road
yeah you're big the big thing in front
of you
is to you know you got you got one year
so let's set some deadlines and say 90
days from today
we will have spent enough time in prayer
in discussion and reading
and learning and uh visiting some people
that are in different
career fields that's right talking to
real cr you know reading everything ken
coleman writes uh and learning about
careers and where you're going to go
to have dialed in and then you say i've
got nine months to get prepared to
start knocking out the things that are
that are going to allow me to go be one
of those
after you've decided what one of those
is
go do that be one of those then talk
about buying a house
how many people over the years dave have
you talked to veterans who come in
and they get that house-buying
quote-unquote benefit
then they find themselves stuck i used
to live
one of the colleges i worked at was next
to a base and it just felt like there
was a rotation
they got a stipend to live off base and
they just go by a house and then in two
years they're getting shipped out
somewhere getting sent out yeah that's a
mess they were
had no money down so they're upside down
upside down yep they're stuck
just feels like people got stuck a lot
yeah the va loan
the sad thing is the va loan for housing
is supposed to be a nice benefit now the
education loan is a nice benefit
but the va loan actually sucks oh yeah
for two reasons one is it's actually
more expensive
it's a higher interest rate and higher
fees which is absolutely
ridiculous you would think that if
you're going to give the veterans a
benefit that it would be
cheaper be better than everybody else
that's right it's not so there you go
there's your veterans administration
working for you
but then the uh uh the second thing is
is they do have this zero down idea
which means the seller pays all the
closing costs you literally can walk in
and sign the papers with not
a dollar and buy a house but you can
never walk out that back door again
exactly but then you owe
100 more than 100
by the time all the stuff's rolled into
the thing of what the house is actually
worth
you know how long it takes to get out of
that five to seven years before you got
enough equity to sell it and break even
and that geez louise yeah this is it's a
nightmare it's a trap
you know don't step there it's gonna rip
your leg off and i know you wanna come
home get plugged in get a house
get those kids everything stable just
hang it there man hang in there
va didn't mean for that to be a trap
they were trying to be nice but nothing
down is not nice
nothing down screws you over and at a
higher interest rate than you could have
gotten if you put down a good down
payment
so no you don't want that benefit you're
right it's a strap
it's a trip this is the ramsey show